ما ان افرجت السلطات الصينيه عن سكانها
بتخفيف قيود فيروس كورونا حتى وقع سكان
الصين بحصار شبه عالمي
كابوس ما خلفه تفشل فايروس من كوارث عاد
الى ادهان الدول فور تجدد عدوه الشرسه
التي تصيب الملايين يوميا في الصين لم
تتردد الدول باتخاذ قراراتها وان بدت
متباينه لكنها اجمعت على خوض حرب الاغلاق
او القيود ضد تفشل فيروس لديها المغرب منع
دخول القادمين من الصين الى اراضيه سبقته
دول في القاره العجوز منها بريطانيا
وفرنسا وايطاليا واسبانيا بفرد قيود على
المسافرين القادمين من الصين تتمثل باظهار
نتيجه فحوصات سلبيه قبل الصعود الى
الطائره كم طردت الذاكره القاسيه الولايات
المتحده وكندا واليابان والهند وماليزيا
لتشترط بدورها فحوصات سلبيات النتائج على
زوار القادمين من الصين بعد انهاء بكين
سياستها صفر
ولاحقا استراليا التي اعلنت عن سريان
قرارها في الخامس من الشهر الحالي وما بدا
لافتا هو عرض المساعده لبكينا الذي تقدمت
به تايوان الساعيه للاستقلال عن الصين بمد
يد المساعده لبكين لمواجهه الارتفاع الحد
بالاصابات بدورها لم تتنازل منظمه الصحه
العالميه عن مطالباتها الحديثه القديمه
للسلطات بكين بمزيد من المعلومات
التفصيليه تحتاجها المنظمه لاجراء تقييم
شامل لمخاطر الفيروس مع مساندتها لاجراءات
الدول التي تهدف لصد الفايروس عن اراضيها
رغم وسط الصين لقرارات تلك الدول
واشتراطاتها بتميزيه حنان المصري العربي